teenage mutant ninja turtles mutant
Mayhem was an abnormal experience for
this cast of voice actors the recording
booth was packed full of improv a ton of
scenes were fully created out of thin
air and even Ice Cube had a lot to say
about the talent behind the scenes so
let's get into it obviously we can't
really imagine anyone else playing these
four iconic mutant Mayhem Turtles then
these four perfectly cast teenage boys
but the audition process wasn't super
cut and dry when it came to placing them
into their perspective Turtle rolls well
for Brady noon it pretty much was I
already knew I like that was the only
role that I was going to play it never
switched I really really full sent it
with with rap Nicholas can't do
originally but ended up getting cast for
Leonardo it wasn't until the chemistry
read that they started playing around
with different roles for the guys you
should try the role Leonardo so they
threw that one my way and I feel like I
connected with it a lot more Micah Abby
originally auditioned for Donatello but
they considered him for Michelangelo
which he wasn't too sure about I'm glad
they gave me Donatello because I love
like I and I truly mean this I literally
love the way that Shimon plays Mikey it
was also pretty cut and dry for Shaman
because he auditioned for Michelangelo
and got a call back pretty quickly he
does this thing where after he auditions
for something he deletes everything
right after so when he got the call back
he was scrambling to remember exactly
what he did to impress like wait what
did I do
so I could nail this again so we know
all the actors were in the same room
with each other but just how close were
they sometimes we were arms length where
we could push each other and things fun
things like that the scene where they
were all talking over each other and
stumbling over each other's lines were
so on point because they were literally
going off of each other's facial
expressions and Body Language be in the
same room with each other and look at
each other look at each other's
reactions to things there are a lot of
lines where they're talking about the
physicality of the scene and it's
actually pretty on point to what's going
on in the booth hey watch out like move
your move your leg like that's because
we're actually in there like interacting
so literally when you're seeing these
Ninja Turtles pushing each other around
on screen that's probably pretty similar
to what's going on behind the scenes
speaking of let's talk about a specific
scene that was fully created out of thin
air by Micah Abby Brady noon Nicholas
Cantu and Shimon Brown we know the movie
is set in New York so obviously the boys
are gonna have a little fun making fun
of your stereotypical New Yorker they
were like yo ah can I get a bacon egg
and cheese and then like Brady would add
in like yo the Aki way the abnormal
thing about the making of this movie is
how much collaboration and improv there
was normally in animated films you
wouldn't even get to meet your cast
members until the day of the premiere
but for this everyone was in the same
room together even at times a bit too
close to each other I'll be getting more
into that later so mine would add in
there and like it just turned into this
like Beast of a scene that came out of
nowhere Ice Cube was stoked that he got
to flex his improv skills most other
animated films he's worked on were
really rigid and every syllable needed
to be just right as it was written
that's awesome little tortoises huh not
on this movie most of the scenes were
full of organic improv comedy you
probably just wouldn't have if it was
just
you know me just doing the recording
them just doing it basically Jeff Lowe
and Seth Rogen would give everyone a
rundown of what scene they were
recording and they were all free to just
riff off of one another you wouldn't
have those little you know natural gems
that land this doesn't mean that nobody
knew their lines in fact it was the
opposite everyone knew exactly what the
script said you know when they know what
they need to say but they act you know
they're ready to rip too Jeff Rowe is
famous for his work on Gravity Falls and
his writing and directing won an
outstanding Achievement Award for the
Mitchells versus the machines he's also
apparently the best guy to work with he
made everyone feel super comfortable and
encouraged the collaboration process as
well as the Improv he also knew exactly
what to say to get the type of improv he
wanted for the scene able to just say
and improv whatever line that makes
sense for that specific part of the
scene even again from Ice Cube's
perspective this was super important
because he was never giving the actors a
hard time if they did something that
wasn't perfect he would just encourage
and ask for more what I've realized you
know in work and he just you could never
do no wrong and truly for anyone who has
ever had a boss you know that's hardly
ever the case Bravo Jeff
teenage mutant ninja turtles mutant
Mayhem is packed full of hilarious
improv a ton of physical acting behind
the scenes and a talented cast and crew
who are more than anything just grateful
to be a part of the project what were
you most surprised to find out about